he's none other than Mike Tirico fresh
from calling and hosting Game seven last
night how are you Mike good morning Rick
just drove past University of Michigan
baseball fields in our burrows you got
you're going to Omaha that's right to
your home you you're you're not in
Boston now terrific I'm glad you're back
I not only did I get an early flight but
doc Emmerich was about a row in front of
me he lives in Michigan so doc and I
were able to share a good Delta flight
on the way home so fun fun run fun night
last night for sure yeah I mean he's
Mike I mean what I want to give you the
floor on him just for a second I
obviously I geek out on announcing for
good reason
I just his choice of words
it is it's like he's playing around with
the English it with a dictionary while
he's got a microphone on he's terrific
and always always had a high
appreciation for for doc going back to
what he was doing the devil's games but
being around him that appreciation has
grown even more and doing three hockey
games this year calling games is it's
such a hard sport to cover as you said
because of the speed the pace of the
game you have no chance to look at a
note or notes during the game and it's
just appreciation for how well he does
it how long he's done it is passion and
connection through the game was
extraordinary you know I think if it was
a young broadcaster coming up
they wouldn't they wouldn't say or
people wouldn't say hey that's a good
style to use because of the amount of
verbage compared to other TV
broadcasters it's all let the pictures
tell the story but Doc's commanded the
language and his use of unique verbs and
adjectives to describe make it
entertaining that that you don't hear
that complained about it he's he's a
wonderful person and extremely talented
and it's been fun for me the last couple
years being at NBC and being around the
finals a few times and other hospitals
to be around him he's a great great man
great man I bet so what was it like in
the building last night it was odd
because Game six in st. Louis had that
letdown atmosphere and so did Game seven
you know the home team with two chances
that I wrote
Wyn does not the road team won five of
the seven games in the series I think
that points to the style of play that
physical style of play from both teams
mixed in with with talent obviously but
our physical made right the thing that
came away with from st. Louis watching
them as the playoffs went along and then
in person during the series so big and
constantly physical every shift somebody
took a Bruin to the boards and a race to
play Patrick sharp who worked with us
who was on three Cup winners with
Chicago said it best to me during I
think was Game one he said it's one two
with the puck and then you get hit and
that takes its toll I think it took its
toll on Boston maybe the moment was too
big at home for st. Louis in Game six
guys you've never been through it but
being on the road feeling less pressure
they played their game they got the
breaks in the first period Binnington
stood on his head hockey term and then
they wrote they wrote that formula all
the way through a good good for them
good for the sport too rich is Vegas
last year getting to the final
Washington winning st. Louis this builds
10-15 years of fandom in those cities
and I was there in Washington but now
they believe in Vegas it started from
scratch st. Louis loyal but the long
wait now you've got other cities to go
along with the ones that are passionate
about like a Boston or a Detroit so I
think good for the league overall as
well
Dannan obviously tonight were some
long-suffering Leafs fans could
celebrate potentially an NBA
championship I mean every single time
you mentioned about a long drought for
for hockey
you know you'll eventually hear about a
Leafs fan that's saying what about me
you know and then there's flier fans
that are raising their hands too so when
you listen to the first segment of your
show when you talked about the poll
question III know the Knicks are there I
forget the other team but the Detroit
Lions and the Toronto Maple Leafs are
the two teams that given the longevity
of the franchise given the passion for
the sport and those are you know
Toronto's and original 16 Detroit Lions
back to Portsmouth and the start of the
NFL given the length of the routes for
both franchises and how long it has been
those fans above all that you met are
the two that are just desperate
desperate those would be the best
parades you could possibly have I tell
people all the time living here in
Michigan Detroit's no his hockey town
with the Red Wings Detroit basketball
the Pistons Tigers had a couple of World
Series runs they the 84 championship
forget all that
if the Lions ever won the Super Bowl
that would be the parade that would end
all parades I would put thee it would be
right up there with the Philadelphia
parade for the Eagles that would be the
one that would be the topper of all
championship parades no kidding cuz you
know I guess people don't think about it
because they don't think it's apps at
all possible to happen Mike I'll give
you a quick story both for sports radio
February Mel Kiper draft expert mock
draft comes out or McShea I agree it was
what it was and it's the first mock
draft the Lions face lines might pick it
tight it which they ended up doing the
tight in Huntington from Iowa well this
is mid separates a mock draft people
were beside themselves because they took
Erika he brought it he wasn't as good I
mean they were there was three hours of
sports talk calls people are so
desperate for know don't make the same
mistake we can't take it anymore it is
as real and as palpable as any sports
drought anywhere in the country so if
that ever happened rich it would be a
cold day in February come to the parade
you'd enjoy Mike Tirico here on the Rich
Eisen show there's also nothing quite
like the handshakes afterwards right
Mike I mean certainly after a cop
- I mean that's there's nothing quite
like it in sports there isn't and and I
got to do I was going to do the rest of
the Pittsburgh Islanders series after
the Masters and it was one game because
the Islanders sweat Pittsburgh and just
to be on the air for the first time and
watched the handshakes was really cool
but I wanted to see last night so my
responsibility is done as the as the
game's over so I was just a fan watching
the end of the third period and then I
doubt after the Bruins went to their
locker room I watched the handshakes
watch the Bruins come past us
and then I walked out of our green room
in the back to come watch the cup be
skated by the Blues I've always wanted
to see that in person and to just see it
up close it's such a childish thing in
so many ways I mean here these guys you
know you think about in the NFL we talk
about your Super Bowl ring baseball the
trophy is nobody cares about the MLB
trophy with all due respect here it's
all about the trophy and the fact that
your name goes on it when these guys get
it and they never touch you I mean they
barely look at it if they haven't won it
but now they get to hold it for the
first time and hold it up and their name
will be on it just to see the joy on
their face when that comes after that
emotion of the team that was that close
in Boston
not doing it how to shake hands with
those guys watch them throw all their
gear up in the air and their barn
another hockey term yes and and then
watch those guys walk off the ice just
and completely crushed and empty it's
it's why all of us who love sports love
sports because we get to see these
unbelievable athletes put everything out
there and we are supremely and
respectfully entertained by what they do
is it's really it keeps us all fans in
addition to doing this for a living well
to bring Detroit sports handshakes and
Mike Tirico here in the rich I should
show our shared experience of Sports
Center all in one one of my favorite
I'll remember when I I one of the first
things I did on SportsCenter you know I
got on there February of 96 and then the
Western Conference Finals of 96 was when
Kris Draper had his jaw rearranged by
Claude Lemieux correct and then right
and then I I I think I did the late
night SportsCenter this is where things
get a little hazy but Ciccarelli saying
he couldn't believe he shook his friggin
hand shook clawed the music friggin hand
we got that soundbite on SportsCenter
and that was just you know that's just
the raw emotions but he still shook his
hand he still shook his freakin end yes
hockey players hockey players are a
different breed and I've always been
told
always experience tangentially that
their their special group of individuals
and being around a little more this year
that's in spades just the young woman is
fighting the young girl yeah Leila
autoimmune disease Leila Anderson
exactly to see the blues not just the
organization invite her get her out
there tickets in his suite have her come
down on the ice and to see kolten Franco
on his knees helping her hold it and
kiss the Stanley Cup I mean that is so
cool and that's hockey and that's what
hockey guys are about and you know that
that image is right up there with the
images of the year in sports no matter
what happens the next six months just to
see that how people can reach out and
the Blues don't just put lip service to
it they they deliver I thought that was
that was one that got me when I was
watching it last night a couple more
minutes left here with Mike Tirico NBC
Sports here in the Rich Eisen show the
US Open how do you see this plan on is
there any shot of Kefka obviously a shot
than winning three straight in a row but
I mean how possible he really is here
Mike yeah I mean it's really possible
Richie he's he's wired he's wired in a
unique way
he loves a challenge he's not gonna back
down from the fact he can become the
first guy in over a century since Willie
Anderson to win the open three times in
a row to backup majors again well he's
the current two-time champ of two
different majors nobody's ever been able
to say that while while holding the
back-to-back trophies from two of the
different majors I was out there for
Golf Channel Monday and Tuesday and now
I know they've started already pebble is
just it's just so good for a US Open
this time of year out there the USDA has
had its struggles the last four or five
US Opens a combination of courses that
were unfamiliar and a couple of whole
locations in big spots on the weekend
that were just poor decisions this is a
perfect place to get right they can have
a really good US Open and because it's
pebble in summer and the rough will be
thick I think it brings more people
in play I think a Jordan speith might
have a good week this week if you are if
you are in position in New York you know
if they driver to be in position I think
you have a chance this week now the
fascinating thing Kefka who hits a deep
and if it is wayward can get out with a
wedge and putt crazy good can he do that
with the rough around the US over short
games magnified his is really good
how will he hold up if he's having a
good ball striking week I think those
are the fascinating things because it's
not a driver dominant week I think
Tigers right in the middle of the mix
here look good feels good I think he's
got a terrific chance as well before I
let you go Mike
well you and I have not spoken since the
Kentucky Derby and you know I'm
wondering what that was like for you
calling you know the post match replay
process I guess that's the only way to
all the things to host in your life on
live TV that's that's a curveball Mike
let's put it that way
we weren't expecting that you know I
mean we have spent probably I don't know
maybe five or six hours of my life at
this point accumulative time discussing
people reviewing replays on TV you know
but I don't think I didn't think it was
ever gonna be one straight 22 minute
shot of it especially in horse-racing
where you know it's funny rich we talked
about replaying sports all the time
replays been in horse racing forever I
mean go back to the 70s with inquiries
and objections and stewards looking at
video and all that stuff so it's been a
part of it for a long long time just
never to see it at the Kentucky Derby
involving the horse that one we were
about a minute and a half two minutes
into the process of talking about no
maximum security and the human
connections that go with it and our
producer Rob Highland gets in my ear and
he said okay hang on a sec and then you
start looking around then the dominoes
began to fall in 22 minutes later we got
a break and go it was it was interesting
it opened some eyes I think I I think
that he
people understand now the process that
horse-racing goes through and it brought
some people who had no idea that that
could be any sort of a foul in
horse-racing into understanding the
sport a little bit differently it set it
set up a very unique rest of the season
for the three-year-olds and I think
going forward created a little bit more
interest in the sport at a time when
they've got their challenges with what's
been going on at Santa Anita but that
was absolutely the most unforeseen plan
at the end of a horse race that we ever
thought we'd go Pat and I went on so
long I actually thought to myself what
if during the NFL replay process that we
could interview the coaches and the
players involved and ask them their
thoughts just like we were watching with
the Kentucky Jerry going up to the
jockey and the trainer and the owners
could you imagine somebody goes up to
Sean Payton Sean what are you thinking
right now while we're reviewing this
play Bob Kraft come over here let me ask
you this question what do you what do
you think about the replay process
that's undergoing right now that could
make a make or break your entire
championship I mean could you imagine
that that would that would be good TV
there's one thing about the horse you
know it's funny in the last six weeks
I've done the Triple Crown races the
Indy 500 the Cup final here and a couple
other things along the way and just
being a part of that stuff how
accessible the athletes are and those
sports that are not the NFL or the NBA
how all the owners and the trainers and
the jockeys they know that they get very
little exposure relative to an NFL
quarterback or an NFL head coach and
they're so good about sharing and the
access to them in that moment was unique
and special and credit to Lafitte
pink-eyed the third and Kenny rice and
Nick luck and our racing group that
they've relationships with them that
they're really comfortable talking to
these guys with the pressures on so it
was uh it was something new something
different but we can today that tap at
us before well you sir you sir if
anybody's deserve to get the time off
for Father's Day it is you happy
Father's Day to you Mike Tirico well
chat soon do you too pal to you too I'm
headed to a
a golf course somewhere to figure out
how bad I really have hit him straight
nonetheless hit him straight no less
enjoyed okay to YouTube but that's a
Mike Tirico for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV for free on BR live or download
the Rich Eisen show app